[Musique]
après les mamans c'est au tour des papas
dimanche c'est la fête des pères une
bonne occasion de faire un joli cadeau
mélanie pour ce rendez vous des juniors
qu'est-ce que vous avez préparé
alors pour une fois j'ai décidé de
plutôt créé l'emballage cadeau est pas
le cadeau lui même une petite boîte 100
% pour les papas comme toujours on
trouve plein d'idées sur le net
moi j'ai craqué sur une petite boîte
chemise cravate à faire à tout âge le
matériel est très simple des feuilles
cartonnées plusieurs couleurs une paire
de ciseaux de la colle ou du scotch et
pourquoi pas des go mettre des
paillettes tout ce qui vous passe par la
tête pour les plus jeunes n'hésitez pas
à imprimer le patron qui se trouve sur
le site qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran pour les plus grands on peut
même aussi créer son propre patron alors
la première étape
bien sûr on découpe au plus près des
traits pour éviter que la boîte soit de
guingois et bien sûr le découper pas les
traits en pointillés ça va permettre de
faire l'intérieur de la boîte et après
on attaque tout de suite à l'étape
pliage alors il faut bien appuyé sur les
pliant pour que ce soit bien nettes et
en plus les pliant en éventail ce n'est
pas le plus facile à faire
non alors pour que les plions pardon
soit le plus net possible
il n'y a rien de plus simple on va
utiliser un petit ciseau mais le dos du
ciseau pour juste faire une petite
marque qui va après aider à plier donc
l'aider mais ça c'est pas de couper mais
de faire une marque un qui aident à
plier et une fois la boîte fort mais il
reste à la ferme et avec du scotch ou de
la colle et oui si vous collez vous
pouvez aussi consolider avec un peu de
cash pôle tes que la boîte se défasse
par contre ne fermait pas la boîte tout
de suite il faut y mettre des cadeaux
alors vous pouvez aussi mettre un tout
petit mot un petit poème
moi j'ai notamment choisi un texte de
pierre rumeau et que j'ai roulé comme un
parchemin et si votre papa le groupement
pourquoi pas des bonbons des petits
gâteaux
vous pouvez après fermer la boîte et
dernière étape la décoration est oui
alors pourquoi pas un petit ne pas
fouler cravate moi j'ai choisi la
cravate bien sûr alors le patron il se
trouve aussi sur le site quand on a
affiché tout à l'heure un petit peu de
colle un petit peu de scotch payet
gommettes si vous voulez la dernière
étape partant de la miss est la plus
dure il faut tendre dimanche
et voilà la jolie boîte à faire pour
vous pas par merci beaucoup mélanie